hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to I can't
help it I'm a product of advertising I
see something advertised I have to go
buy it
Borden's but that doesn't mean there
aren't some advertising gimmicks or
characters they work better than others
like this one too
take for example cereal labels there are
dozens of cereals out there but only a
distinct few seem to survive over the
years is it really the taste of the
cereal that keeps kids coming back or is
it the mascots the timeless characters
that go for many changes but still keep
the same likeability over the decades no
it's obviously the taste but the mascots
play a big role and that's why I'm
counting down the top 11 best
sugar-coated marketing icons of all time
why Kop 11 cuz I like to go and step
beyond so sit back and enjoy the top 11
greatest cereal mascot milk and cereal
cereal cereal milk and cereal cereal mmm
Sylvia Sylvia cereal milk cereal
number one toucan sam from Froot Loops
released in around 1945 to King Sam
started off with a relatively boring
scenario just talking in piglet crispy
and delicious name bought breakfast on
phone a King sling riveting mark kid
by the way that always sounds different
to you that's because it wasn't always
done by the same person
in fact that's actually Mel Blanc the
voice of most of the Looney Tunes
characters but they didn't feel like the
character was strong enough so they
switched out the voices with tall fries
another actor who might sound familiar
some punk a dog skirt loops oh you know
did you hear that nut yes it's the same
guy who did Ludwig von drain what I'm
telling you they also change the
scenario around to it usually starts off
with somebody having a problem or
searching for something no matter what
the dilemma Froot Loops always seems to
have the answer they left without
breakfast again gonna fit four days away
title in frozen breakfast I need a
really rad breakfast and he'll get me
back Oh column I know just follow my
nose follow my nose ah kennels Froot
Loops cereal just how many problems can
Froot Loops change anyway
oh geez - can't say my father has AIDS
then follow your nose well ok it always
knows
one cookie I can do cereal
oh my father still has AIDS well
whatever the issue there was always a
big bowl of fruit love cereal there to
make you forget about all your promise
our Lee's Prime another football fan and
I got great pain like me damn my father
still has 8's a real serial ml number 10
ml to be on ml cookie crook and officer
crumb now technically these characters
aren't around anymore but I want to list
them just to show the evolution of a
character originally released in 1977
the mascot for Cookie Crisp was
originally a wizard named Jarvis isn't
that aware named his gimmick was to turn
serial holes into big pots of cookies
you know because our Syrio Forel right
so boring I think a John very well so
they changed it in 1985 to a disruptive
pair called cookie crook and officer
from this caught out much better but it
still wasn't gimmicky enough if only
there was an annoying catchphrase that
every kid could be shouting obnoxiously
grid so they gave the cookie crooked dog
named chip who would ruin everything by
always shoving oh I get rich oh man that
did even better so after a while they
just said fuck the cops and robbers will
just make it about the door so the dog
was a mascot for a while I was a mouth
full of chips and everybody but they
didn't think the design was hip enough
for the young kids so they decide
redesign it and make it into a wolf or
husky I'm not sure what it is and made
the change complete by giving him a
sports jacket what you can't see the
natural evolution of going from a Merlin
style wizard into a sports centered
husky Oh someone needs to take some
logic classes for all the changes and
went through the cookie croaking cop
were the best additions because hey who
doesn't love a good game of cops and
robbers well ok cops and robbers but
still it was a good idea
lasting almost eight years and
commercials that's one tough cookie
that's hard to beat
hey Chris hey grandpa ho a good mother
please complete breakfast cereal cereal
mmm number not to be on mmm to be on mmm
the honey nut cheerios B they'll not
having much of a character this B was
certainly enjoyable to watch making any
real-life B's look like fucking monsters
this gimmick was to try and get people
to try his cereal but they never seemed
interested until he said the magic words
mime you attempted with that tasty nuts
and honey nuts and honey nuts and honey
do you see honey I'm not did you say
hookers and blow oh no you said honey
and nuts that that's not nearly as good
actually I always like watching this
commercial in particular around
Christmastime then the fruity pebbles
commercial with Santa and no they're not
gonna make it on the countdown because
they're already on a show it's like
putting Jack's better on the list
because of the Pirates of the Caribbean
Sea really it just doesn't seem right
that may promote smoking dude that's
just wrong
hey babe it's funny that we all just
call him B because he actually was given
a name in 2002 held a contest for who
and named the honey nut cheerios being a
fifth-grader won the prize by naming him
are you ready for this buzz be really
that's the most imaginative name you
could pay from the list well while
you're at why'd you just call these
characters squeak mocks fly bird or
shits fewer the possibilities are just
endless well to me he's the humming nut
cheerios being sure it's a long name but
a mascot by any other name would still
be as marketable or should I say be
marketable
oh no that bees cilia be stretching out
the middle of a word for no reason yes
there we go see beyond mm no Maury
beyond mmm do beyond mmm Wendell from
cinnamon toast crunch getting it start
in 1987 cinnamon toast crunch didn't
just have Wendell but actually two other
chefs what were their names
nobody knows in fact Wendell is the only
one who ever had a name and identity out
of these three it's a little stranger
they were a trio for a while until this
long commercial had Wendell suck himself
into a television because he was
distracted by the cinnamon toast crunch
those on the TV
crazy which is odd because he makes this
stuff and he's surrounded by it isn't it
kinda like watching porn when he owned a
bordello the other chefs got him back
but the gimmick was now changed now the
scenario was Wendell would go crazy
every time he saw him and toast crunch
and would immediately go after it and
where did the other two chefs go nobody
knows
my guess is Wendell had them assassinate
somewhere at the bottom of the ocean
you'll find two chefs with cement shoes
and cookie crock next to a cookie cop
they had to go somewhere
since then the focus seemed in fear away
from Wendell and instead showed off
other people who could see everything
except white kids love cinnamon toast
crunch which is II know why kids love
cinnamon toast crunch
animal vegetable or mineral I just don't
know well isn't it obvious it's covered
in crack the sugar is just a cover
that's pure 100% well how would you ever
wonder why your kids get so active after
they eat it whatever does go into those
crystals you can always be sure that
there's a creepy old man you're there to
make it don't be part of a complete
breakfast a real serial number so you be
on mmm do be on mmm lucky from Lucky
Charms
not too much has changed with him over
the years literally from day one the
gimmick has always been the same catch
lucky and you get his lucky charm Geordi
be free ham rock can't your pack of
Lucky Charms okay what the hell's our
kid doing with handcuffs
Oh getting it started in 1962 lucky was
originally known as Elsie leprechaun
well what did the Elsie stand for Oh
Lucky Charms yeah I'm a fucking idiot
autumn green and blue marshmallows at
every spoonful a magical cage for you
too much to say about him just that kids
love chasing after things so the idea of
trying to catch something to gain reward
is always foolproof did she
never stops but would you be pissed off
if you caught a leprechaun and instead
of gold you got a friggin bowl of cereal
did you punch me did you get me lucky
charms
no I go hey you want a Lucky Charms no I
want the gold I know you want a lucky
chance in quite positive I want to go
quick if you want to deny the sweet
taste there now you're dead how do you
like that an idea so basic it has to be
admired lucky is the perfect prize to
catch it or smash at the end of any
rainbow
necessary oh do be on ml number to be on
ml to be on ml Captain Crunch from well
kept a crock is it me or is this guy the
snagglepuss of cereal mascots Adam
Crunch with crunch berries next time
let's not wish quite so hard and
remember to exit stage right
actually Captain Crunch was another
character that started out with an
entire cat there was a dog for annoying
kids and an evil pirate named look what
a pendulum was replaced by the soggy
these big puddles of splooge with eyes
that like to make everything you guessed
it soggy yeah but good they also had
some sort of evil machine that led the
Saudis but I can't really remember isn't
anybody the scenario would have been
fine and good except that they actually
turned it into a straight-up
war I mean it was like a soap opera with
gun spaceships giant robots kind of get
out of control this is quite far
sorry no let's move on to waterboarding
them I'm not sure the Saudis are still
around but the captain sure is in fact
they even revealed his entire name at
one winter calling him captain Horatio
Magellan crutch because every kid would
remember that name koonta :
show always crunchy never soggy Captain
Crunch still remains the captain that
can make it happen
botch go sea dog I hate to see a grown
Huayra cry yes sir BL see beyond ml
number five e on ml Jimmy on M milk
count shockula from Count Chocula
speaking from a health point of view
what's worse than marshmallows in your
cereal how about chocolate marshmallows
in chocolate cereal want you to throw in
miniature cheeseburgers liner at well as
horrible as it is for you it tasted
great and have a great mascot in fact it
was so good that there were actually
cereal spin-offs as ironic because the
more healthy they got but less
successful they did like Franken berries
still sort of around blueberry you
barely see and who the hell even
remembers fruit ooh yummy mummy what was
vegetable Lecter too good a name to take
well we still love the characters it was
kind of clever that they always took the
voice of the movie monster they were
spoofing like how Chocula is da Lugosi
and you lose all my gun Franken berries
Boris Karloff Frank and Betty has a draw
that ain't livin sweetie
for some reason blueberry was Peter
Lorre with my haunting Lee delicious
cereal did he ever play a ghost no well
he's dead now so maybe that comes but
either way it was Count Chocula that
brought in the big bucks at the
healthiest cereal but hey that's why we
loved it so much how about that mom
goodbye break huh good yes
viviana number four to be on mmm to be
on mmm
sunny from Cocoa Puffs sunny is just an
addict okay he needs help he needs to go
into rehab and have his illness treated
look at it he's just trying to do is
everyday work when suddenly these little
bungholes come up and tempt him by
feeding his habit what's up with those
kids they're fucking enablers hey you
want some stuff you want some stuff I
got some good stuff right here yeah yeah
that's cocoa meth right there man yeah
crystal pot get your nice and saucy
fucked up but don't blame the kids blame
this grandpa who started out pushing the
stuff back in the 60s I'll should be
things up go Sonny can't British cocoa
puffs you would do this in every
commercial what a dick after grams
disappeared I'm assuming died from some
sort of overdose Sonny was left on his
own high his inner demons every day for
the rest of his poor soul we may never
know what he's like as the sober Bert
by the way do you know who originally
did the voice for Sonny you would never
guess in a million years get crabs for
me free and conquer pops
that's right it's the guy who did lion-o
from Father cats what the hell happens
to a guy who goes from a butch manly
superhero - a crazy addicted bird I'll
tell you what happens pops happens
everyone thinks Lindsay Lohan got
addicted to drugs not a chance it was
pops
Tennessee Williams addicted to alcohol
not even his pops pops pops pops
remember kids life may be rough but
don't do the puffs
it wasn't glamorous or a cool but kids
step
yes there we go Tyrion mm not for Jimmy
on mmm
Jimmy on ml sugar mare from golden Chris
I love this guy
this is the most laid-back character who
always somehow manages to kick ass
Oh in a bowl he's like if the dude was
on steroids he's frickin awesome
I ain't getting up super golden Chris
it's kinda cranky with punch he
surprisingly started out on a show
called - the Lionheart who actually
hosted a slew of characters that have
their own series did you see did you see
him watch it again
Kevin bear how funny is that all these
overblown characters and the one that
makes it big is the very last one I
don't know if you did well because of
Assyria or if the cereal did well
because of him but he stuck around and
like most cereals golden crisp then
called sugar Chris seemed to be the one
entity that could solve all the world's
problems hey grab your bleep yeah I
don't care bear well I do so put out the
fire clear up the air keep that Al Gore
hmm you deserve a revolver chicken super
sugar crisp is my reward
yeah he's just like fuck off bitch I got
some cereal dont that good and I want
Tom eventually the story became that all
these evil baddies would try to steal
his golden Chris what up fellas
yo time cover Brad come on this is he
popped a few in his mouth he became like
Popeye and kick dings that snakes biting
history yeah I can't get to nothing me
Golden Fleece I cook a cake a cake every
man is born with a great
there's an even stranger plot Betty bald
where he constantly tries to steal gold
and crisp from an old lady isn't that a
little um whoa
here comes that singing bear again to
steal my pony Lucas cereal I think that
well there's anyone that can make Robbie
from the elderly cool
it's sugar bear always smooth always lay
back and always pay I can't get enough
soup Oden crisp it's got the Grinch with
Syrio number two Simeon ml Simeon ml the
Trix rabbit from Trix
this character is like a Greek tragedy
along with Oedipus and Antigone the Trix
rabbit will always be remembered as a
great tragic figure all he wants is Trix
just a sip a little cereal that he
decided to devote his entire life to but
when the kids ever give him the damn
stuff look and why she can't because
they're fucking assholes that's why it's
like the natural order of things the
world goes around the Sun always comes
up and the trees rabbit must suffer how
horribly cruel silly rabbit tricks
Cooper kids know me what did he ever do
to any other human being just cut him a
break I'm gonna get me a drink
look even Santa steals from him what a
jolly ol prick even with the help of
Bugs Bunny he could never seem to get
any am I gonna miss any for you make
that bunny
I'd Reaper a happy Indian guy that's
pretty bad when even bugs can't stand
and watch your misery oh there's even
this wrong commercial I love where you
think he's finally gonna get it after
all these years picture the kids well
therefore milk bastard so I guess the
Trix rabbit is a way of showing kids
humanity's unnatural cruelty to others
it's not right it's not fair but you
gotta just deal with it
drink some four cubes motherfucker ha ha
the trace red because hey we're just
flat out save your fell for that one man
Savio Divya and the number one greatest
cereal mascot is Tony the Tiger from
frosted flakes this is the cereal icon
we all wanted to be the sports star the
guy that said if you just eat my
sugar-coated crusty paper you'll be
unstoppable like me good how can you not
like this guy he's strong he's athletic
and has a clean personality unlike some
of the other addicts on this countdown
every ad seemed the same you got some
kid who was being made fun of before the
big game
you up a little game I wanna take a
horsey ride hey with IRA that you cried
when your mother got slaughtered by your
drunken father who then Tony's frosted
flake seems to give the kid the extra
energy that he or she
who let the tiger out of the ice
no plastic flakes the middle finger of
breakfast actually Tony started out in
1958 and even had a son named Tony jr.
sugar frosted flakes by Kellogg's out of
Battle Creek his voice was different too
it was done by Dallas McKennon who you
may recognize from that Haunted Mansion
ride where boy then the voice was
continued by Thoreau rabbits grunt who
sang a lot of the songs from How the
Grinch Stole Christmas you show him but
first let's start with a complete
breakfast including my frosted flakes
but after his death in 2005 they gave
the child to lead Marshall we're still
doing it today he was the only cereal
mascot who actually kind of seemed like
a role model who is cool strong just
secure - you can look up - tiger
example
Tony the Tiger if you didn't like him
then you're a cool pretty big douchebag
and those are the top 11 greatest cereal
mascot I hope you enjoy them and before
I go I'd like to acknowledge all the
poor souls who sadly lost their lives to
the addiction that is Coco Puffs
optimist - my Brutes you don't have to
you